nous avons décidé remettre les tpe ward
une magnifique banane doré qui ornera
votre mes salles à manger votre cheminée
quatre catégories dont 4 p a remporté à
chaque fois trois nommés parmi vous sont
en compétition
tu me fais peur sur la tête de ma mère
le gagnant
tekori si vous êtes d'accord première
catégorie qui fait non mais cyril aller
il est pas bien sérieux et le patac là
dans la catégorie j'ai pris un vent
énorme tellement énorme qu'il a été
requalifiée en ouragan de catégorie 4
les nommés sont regardés en image de
l'amour
je pose une question qu'on est on me le
fait vite remarquer pourquoi pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils s'appellent jean marc
parce que mathieu c'était trop con jean
michel maire pour remis à sa place
devant deux millions de téléspectateurs
vous avez tort parce que je suis super
résistante mais je suis au service de la
collectivité
erika moulet pour je prends un vent et
en même temps un râteau avec lui tous
les jours avec les jours je pense
qu'eric un préféré skier avec moi à ça
et j'ai pris un vent tellement énorme
qu'il a été requalifiée en ouragan le
lauréat qui va repartir avec la banane
d'or de cathy guetta arthur il s'agit de
j'en ai choisi
misère
je pense que moi si c'est le match c'est
le moment de rendre hommage à
l'accessoiriste parce qu'il a ici à
prendre l'avion porte-manteau question
est une vraie bonne équipe mais pas les
doigts le sua qui se détache et craquait
alors dans la catégorie 2e catégorie je
suis venu en taxi dans tpm paix je suis
reparti en ambulance tellement j'ai été
traumatisé voici les nominés jean michel
maire pour je suis le fils de guillaume
tell et comptant en plus regardées
matthieu delormeau pour son rôle de
charmeurs de serpents
et tarek boudali pour il ya un cocktail
dans mon slip
dans la catégorie je suis venu dans tpm
paix je suis reparti en ambulance
tellement j'étais traumatisée elle the
winner is alors
il a tué l'amour
et il est affreux ce trophée on dirait
un vieux bois des années 4
sur double faute et une série mais on
continue syrie
ouf
vous aider
allez on enchaîne s'il vous plaît on est
prêtes les sacs amis dans la catégorie
je suis ceinture noire de coup de gueule
il faut pas me chercher des sinon tu vas
prendre un coup donné je les découvre en
même temps que vous les nominés sont
gilles verdez cours
oui mais avec de longs alors de longs
toi là les lexiques symbole moi je vais
te dire si tu en a dans le pantalon de
l'ont vu ici leur parler à ses millions
mais tu viendras pas de l'eau tu
viendras pas parce que t'as jamais rien
eu dans le pantalon et dolo ça rime avec
potron gilles verdez pour son coup de
gueule hypnotique qui a duré une heure
cinquante
moi j'ai un coup de gueule c'est quoi
c'est quoi contre le maire jean michel
maire qui racontent n'importe quoi qui
dit que rihanna qui fait sur lui au parc
des princes dimanche soir lors de psg om
il a dit ça j'ai bondi hier il a dit ça
ici et gilles verdez pour sa déclaration
d'amour à frédéric lopez
mais moi ce que j'ai à lui dire à
monsieur frédéric lopez avait détruite
la folie elle et pète pas singer mi mai
avec vous le foutage de gueule il est
permanent
quel suspense mesdames et messieurs quel
système est quand même montré
l'enveloppent parce que tout est
collector
gilles verdez
gina qui pourra dire aux téléspectateurs
pour ce trophée
ah oui c'est fantastique the rain marché
arthur parce que c'est le gars mais une
tannée en deux secondes alors on adore
cette agressive arrêter d'être agressive
à gré si on fait la dernière catégorie
dans la catégorie la crème je la mange
pas je préfère me la prendre en pleine
poire les nominés sont vaincus j'en
viens vous cobourg son auto tarte
cyril hanouna pour retrouvailles
chaleureuses entre amis merci c'est une
vraie surprise
on se met la tête j'y rentre la tête
c'est qui mais je dois dire ce que c'est
enora malagré pour je l'avais pas vu
venir celle là
et le long et on a gagné pas là c'est
enora malagré gaga
c'est donc matthieu delormeau qui va
prendre le trophée au nom d'une huawei
de la piste biche
voilà matthieu delormeau regarder aller
voilà c'est pourquoi mon petit clapot
merci deux balades et content d'avoir
des malades
tu auras la savoie la suite qu'est ce
qui se passe qu'est ce qu'il a pensé
bien autour d'eux nus qu'il advient
condition grosso et j'apprécie
on fera la guerre cela soit parce que
j'espère il paraît que j'ai un prix
voilà mais têtue un prix d'honneur donc
pour lequel n'y a pas besoin de voter
vous verrez qu'elle c'est du poisson
c'est le seul mec en france qui peut
avoir ce prix vous comprendrez pourquoi
demain et c'est une grosse déconne c'est
une parodie des cérémonies intérêt
sérieux en samu est sérieuse on l'a fait
sérieusement avec un des journalistes
qui ont voté tous les résultats sont
sérieux mais l'émission est une grosse
déconne il ya un prix pour lesquels il
faut que ben a tout effacé ceux qui
téléchargent l'api pour voter pour toi
abbas et pour la meilleure coiffure
voilà